我们是
我们很高兴能在这里
因为在1919年那是我第一次参加GDC
我无法想象在接下来的三年里世界变成了什么
但我们在这里
我们很幸运
我知道这场流行病对你们来说已经结束了一段时间
但在中国，我们只是在
去年年底
所以我们很高兴来到这里
能够来到这里
我们应该感谢你
感谢主办方
我们应该为我们所有人鼓掌
我们已经经历过了
谢谢你
所以回到我们今天的会议
我们将讨论随机图
它是渲染管道的基础设施
这真的是很低级的事情
自从GDC17首次引入框图以来，也有一些类似的解决方案
我们想要分享的是一个面向数据的解决方案
首先让我们自我介绍一下
我叫金玲
现在是COCOS发动机的技术总监
我的主要角色是建立可可的引擎团队和博士将军
下面是渲染管道的主要架构师
他喜欢游戏引擎编程
在腾讯巨人等有过多次项目经历
他加入COCOS设计下一代渲染管道基础设施
在今天的谈话中
我们将首先介绍我们的开源引擎
然后我要给你看一个免费的样品
我们为渲染图构建
带着演示
视觉上的想法
我将通过一般来谈论设计上下文
以及我们如何创造性地将图算法应用到随机图中
好啦
我们开始吧
Cocos以前是众所周知的二维游戏框架
就像可可两个D和可可到DX
在手机游戏的早期
它是最早同时支持iOS和Android的游戏引擎之一
它也是最稳定的
轻量级兼容的游戏引擎
记住所有那些方形屏幕或横向屏幕的搁浅形式
即使有物理学
物理键盘
所以这是一个非常成功的引擎
它们适应了大多数，运行没有任何问题
最重要的是，从一开始，它就是一个非常成功的开源项目
我们很擅长
喜欢你你
你会看到数据
有多少人喜欢这个项目
有多少贡献者
然后我们开始将coco移植到许多不同的平台上
Coco的创造者是我们作为主流产品推出的一个项目
其中包括一个多合一游戏编辑器
从那时起，工作流程发生了根本性的变化
在2020年，我们推出了《创作者》的第三版
它是一个完整的三维游戏引擎
顺便说一下
我真的很喜欢名字创作者
这意味着我们都是游戏的创造者
直到今天
Coco创建者的引擎仍然是开源的
不仅引擎是开源的
我们还依赖于许多其他开源项目
喜欢电子是我们编辑的基本框架
物理X和物理V8的板作为我们的脚本引擎
用于级别渲染的自由类型
用于多任务处理的一个API中的TBB
最后用升压图作为图的算法
库作为引擎本身
我们也有很多社区贡献者
所以如果你喜欢这个项目，请开始，如果你感兴趣，请加入社区
从开发人员的角度来看
作为一个开源项目
有很多好处
首先用源代码
他们可以更好地理解发动机
然而，一切都实现了
它帮助他们调试或从发动机设计中学习
第二
很容易扩展引擎与任何类型的项目需要
我们有一个官方支持的自定义工作流
第三是易定制的易定制的一种结果
用户觉得他们在控制之中
尽管发动机不可能完美地适用于各种项目
安全感很重要
如右图所示
无论什么平台
他们发布包中的所有东西都是百分之百可控的
再往前
有开发商深度参与
他们真的很高兴知道路线图和引擎的方向
他们愿意参与
4.我们非常感激他们为这个项目所做的一切
但更重要的是，开源帮助我们与开发人员建立了信任
所有的拉请求和问题都与社区共享
我们还使用GitHub作为自己的内部任务管理系统
全都是透明的
现在让我们进入技术是
这是发动机的整体结构
我会和你分享
今天我们谈的内容是什么
从下到上
平台层包括一个平台抽象层和cocos创建者支持的所有平台
大家可以看到
平台众多
基础设施层包括所有核心系统
我们为用户API提供组件
最后，用户用可定制的管道资产和项目逻辑构建了自己的游戏
所以我们今天关注的是渲染器
基础结构层内的渲染器模块
需要注意的是，开发人员可以轻松地在组件级别定制所有内容
和图形级别
但是对他们来说，定制基础设施模块是极其困难的
我相信每个引擎都是这样
因此，基础结构设计定义了发动机的可访问性和稳定性
很快的
这真的很关键
接下来是我们今天的重点
随机图是渲染器中的基础结构
它使用GFX图形API，并提供租用渲染管道的数据
使用呈现图的API集
我们建造前进的引擎和不同的管道
在演示中，我们将介绍它
在项目级别使用随机图编写一个全新的呈现管道
使用打字API
这个自定义呈现管道实现了引擎所不具备的许多特性
然而，它在编辑器和运行时都取代了引擎管道
所以我们将专注于发动机的这个小但关键的部分
介绍其好处
剥到它的核心设计
在我们深入了解之前
让我们首先通过我们的新示例项目来看看实际情况
这是一个赛博朋克风格的第三人称射击演示
希望你喜欢这些图形
它支持桌面
移动原生
和每个平台上的网络平台
它使用最原生的方式在桌面和Android上实现它
我们用的是Vulkan
在iOS上
我们用的是金属
我们用的是WebGL网络二号
在移动平台上
网络平台
而且演示可以在每个旧设备上顺利运行
在非常旧的设备上
就像iPhone7
三星的八个
像素二
这是编辑器视图
可以看到烟雾效果的反光道具
整件事
现在在我们店里免费下载
你可以在可可商店搜索赛博朋克演示
它包括整个项目的资源和源代码
所以请随时下载并试用
有一个可视化工具来显示呈现管道
用呈现图构建
在这个项目中
我们有三个管道，你可以在面板中看到
在呈现流水线图面板中
第一个是反射支柱烘烤管道
它在编辑器中脱机使用
所以第二个是用来UI渲染的
它是一个用于呈现管道的
第三个是主渲染管道
使用延迟呈现管道
你可以看到有时间分析和FSR
引擎不支持这些功能
所以现在我们可以把它们
我们可以把图形
我们将默认的照明通道直接连接到TA A通道
布隆通道已经关闭
你可以看到灯光消失了，扫帚照明也消失了
现在我们是
有点快
注意屋顶上的光线
现在又开始了
所以很神奇对吧
你真的可以在飞行中动态控制事情
这一切都依赖于随机图
这只是我们的随机图所能支持的一个最小的东西
所以足够做背景了
现在呢
请让您指导您通过图形的实际设计
嗨，大家好
我是日记和核心小组渲染管道的引擎架构师
在介绍我们的渲染图之前
让我们先谈谈框图
框图由Frost团队首次引入
之后，开发了许多变体，并在游戏引擎中采用
比如统一和虚幻引擎
框架图建立了对整个框架的高水平知识，有很多好处
它简化了资源管理
它简化了呈现流水线配置
我想这也简化了
C计算与障碍
框架图允许自包含和高效的渲染模块
渲染通行证和计算机通行证
其他特性，如可视化和调试，可以建立在帧图的顶部
我们的新方法也受到帧图的启发
但它是面向数据的
在我们面向数据的方法中
我们不仅收集管道相关信息
但也呈现相同的信息
随机图是一个依赖呈现任务的完整描述
它包含执行任务的所有信息
与框图的比较
我们在这样一个面向数据的环境中使用声明式编程进一步简化了管道配置
管道设置了一个与执行阶段一起解压缩的阶段
然后，我们可以在不调用管道的情况下验证管道
使得单元测试更容易
面向数据方法的另一个好处是可以修改和转换呈现图
这意味着我们可以根据用户输入图动态生成新的图
这是框图和我们的方法的主要区别
我会再解释一点
在框图中
用户向系统提供C++回调，并让它调度回调
这种设计模式被称为控制反转
这是重用代码的好方法
但是
在我们设置好框图之后
系统可能没有机会改变图表
因为回调是用代码编写的
在我们面向数据的方法中
我们使用呈现命令的描述来替换这些回调
使用我的红色设置代码构建管道描述
然后送到引擎执行
我们的方法更直接
在多线程中，用户不需要关心竞争条件
我们的呈现图由两种类型的图组成
第一个作为命令图
命令图是我们的基本图
它分层存储呈现命令
在顶层
有渲染通行证
它们将绑定呈现目标或表示计算机任务
在下一个层次上
我们可以在通行证上附加随机线索
租赁提示只控制内容的呈现顺序
在一个呈现队列中呈现所有内容之后
另一个呈现队列将开始呈现它们
在底层
将渲染命令的三个d场景添加到队列中
未指定一个q中内容的呈现顺序
内容可以以任何顺序呈现
命令图是图论中的森林
大家可以看到
一个图中可以有多个树
就像屏幕上的那些
第二类图是依赖图
在命令图的顶部
我们将覆盖一个依赖关系图
它定义了帧图资源中的数据依赖关系
例如纹理或缓冲区使用资源节点表示
这个资源节点将连接到呈现传递
在我们的情况下
仅称为名称的资源
作为经常资源的把柄
资源连接到雷达通道的输入和输出插槽
我们将连接不同的租赁通行证，如果他们的插槽共享相同的名称
在这个图中
亮度纹理与照明脉冲的输出绑定
以及后处理路径的输入
所以这两个通道是相连的
所以海报
因此，后处理通行证取决于照明通行证
最后会有一个隐含的边缘
其来源作为照明通行证，目标作为后处理通行证
总结一下，我们的呈现图是这两种类型图的组成
随机图一个图
依赖关系图
下面是另一个例子
通过添加呈现传递和呈现队列
我们可以根据用户需要构建复杂的渲染流水线
下面是我们的设置代码示例
它通常是用脚本类型编写的
它实际上调用c++函数
并将在引擎盖下构建数据结构
因此，在Typescript中声明的呈现图可以在Web和本机引擎中执行
用户也可以直接使用C Plus Plus API构建渲染图
因为我们的引擎是开源的
存储库中还有更多可用的示例
你也可以参考我们的赛博朋克演示
渲染图组成后
我们可以编写一个编译器来验证图的完整性
然后我们可以将每个传递安排到一个执行设备
Q和根据时间表插入屏障
这个过程与框图中的过程相同
不同的是，我们没有回调，用户输入可以转换
让我们看一个例子
例如
如果我们要调试存储在Radiance纹理中的照明结果
我们可以插入一个新的复制通行证
以亮度纹理作为输入
并将其复制到一个新的纹理中进行可视化
插入后
我们可以编译
用完全相同的过程验证和执行随机图的转换
在这种情况下
用户代码和引擎代码都不修改
用户不知道正在调试呈现管道
雷达
屏幕上的结果会是一样的
而且执行人不知道它是用来调试的
用户管道
它只需要任何有效的图
就这样
我们实现了代码的重用和简化
实现用户还可以扩展具有复杂渲染器功能的引擎
我们的安装朋克演示就是一个很好的例子
下一个
让我们来谈谈描述符布局图
仅仅渲染图形是不够的，它需要着色器信息
例如在我们的引擎中设置描述符和绑定
我们将在一个设置的输入阶段收集所有着色器信息
我们将组织这些信息并计算所描述的集合布局
看看例子
这里的着色器a和θb使用了不同的描述符
我们在切换着色器时需要重新绑定集合
优化渲染过程
我们可以根据这些描述符的更新速率合并它们
例如
光率图和LUT是一次通过
所以在最后的布局中它们会被放在同一套里
对于高对于高数据速率描述符
我们将保留每种描述符类型的容量，如第二组所示
就这样
我们可以一次通过绑定集合零
然后我们为不同的着色器分别绑定两个集合
以下是我们的优化算法概述
该算法建立在数据结构之上
我们称之为描述符布局图
是呀
另一张图
首先
我们将从着色器到随机相位节点收集描述符信息
第二
我们合并所有传递描述符来呈现传递节点
和计算机一个恒定的布局
最后，我们将用新的布局覆盖着色器
此布局信息将在呈现图中每个节点的呈现图执行期间使用
根据布局
我们将获取相应的资源并填充描述符集
最后
我们将解释如何实现这些图
我们使用开放源码库来降低开发成本
让我们从为什么需要一个好的图书馆开始
在为游戏引擎编写模块时
我们将分析并选择性能更好的数据结构
例如
如果图被实现为结构数组
可能会导致缓存丢失
因为顶点对缓存来说太大了
用户只能访问顶点的子集
我们可以将数据结构更改为数组结构，以提高缓存性能
但是我们需要分析它来分析这两个数据结构
用户代码不应更改
因为反映一个基本的数据结构真的很痛苦
因此，我们希望在随机图中有相同的访问接口来实现不同的实现
我们使用了一个通用的图接口来解决这个问题
我们的工作是建立在助推器图上的
一个开源的泛型图库
几十年来一直被广泛使用
就像STL助推器
图使用迭代器来分离接口和实现
它的开销为零
它也有许多图形算法，我们可以开箱即用
大大降低了我们的开发成本
游戏引擎里有很多图表
如渲染图
场景图
说图形动画
图行为
树
任务查找等
它们都可以通过使用泛型图接口而受益
泛型图接口建立在图的概念上
不同的图需要不同的概念
例如
深度优先搜索需要方向图
双向图
对于属性访问，它需要属性图
我们也可以在我们的行为中加入新的概念
例如
我们添加了一个可寻址图的概念来支持通过遍历查找顶点
我们实际上自己实现了图的大部分
我们只使用Boost提供的算法
它展示了Boost是如何解码接口和实现的
支持这些概念
我们使用代码生成器来生成C中的图代码
Plus Plus并为我们的Web和本机引擎键入脚本
生成器是用C++编写的
用户可以使用C++注册图形
但它也提供了一个dsl来简化使用
专业人士被称为
代码生成器比模板实现更通用，更容易编写
所以不需要模板元编程
而且输出代码更容易阅读
缺点是代码生成器引入了另一层
可能不适合很多用户
我们还需要注册很多类型来生成代码
下面是一些用打字稿写的图概念的例子
这里列出了常见的概念
它们一般来自升压图
你可以看一下演示文稿
以下是我们新引入的一些概念
它们是一个名为图的分量图
父树可寻址图
多态图
和UID图
我们的租赁图和布局图建立在这些概念之上
用于租赁图
它是双向图
这是一个顶点列表图
所以每个顶点都可以迭代
它是这个图的边缘
并且支持组件到图
所以这是一个数组的结构
每个顶点都有名字
所以它被命名为图表
命令图是一棵树
也是一个多态图
所以每个顶点都有自己的类型
顶点是多态的
图形的布局是一样的
它是双向的
它是顶点列表
它有组件，它有名称
它是一个父图
所以每个顶点都有它的父母和他们的孩子
它也是可寻址图
所以我们可以用一个路径来查找顶点
顶点可以是多态的
下面列出了一些有用的链接
它们是项目下载
网络扑克演示和我们的推特
所以谢谢你的倾听